hello this video is all about traversing
the Dom using jQuery it's all about
trying to find specific HTML elements
based on the relation to other elements
you can find parent elements child
elements I have this HTML set up in here
to show a lot of different parent
elements and child elements you can see
how one element is related to another
because these green boxes basically show
what elements contain other elements I
just have CSS that applies everything to
make this all work here so you can see
this div is the parent of this unordered
list here and you can see this unordered
list is the child of the div here we
have a bunch of children of this span
also all these elements here in the
middle our siblings of each other
they're all on the same level you can
see that same thing in the HTML that's
how you can tell parents and children
okay I'm gonna bring up the JavaScript
here so we can just focus on the jQuery
we're gonna use I've already added
jQuery to the project you can check my
first video in this series to learn how
to do that okay I just paste it in some
code here we have the jQuery selector to
select the the Li element and here's
here's the new thing we're learning dot
parent now we're gonna get the parent of
the LI element and then we're just going
to change the CSS we're gonna change the
color chocolate and the border is also
gonna be changed to chocolate
I decided to use a tasty color this time
so let's run that and you can see the
parent of the LI element has turned to
chocolate so here's the LI element and
here's the parent the UL element now if
I change this to span here I run that
the interesting thing about that is
there are two spans we have the span
here and we have the span here the
parent of this ban is the Li the parent
of this man is the other span another
thing we can do is instead of using
parent do parents plural with an S at
the end that's gonna get all the parents
all the way up to the root
so if I run that you can see now there's
a bunch of things even things that we
didn't even know about including this
other div here I have turned to
chocolate border now another one we can
do to find parents let's find the parent
of the Li element so instead of parents
here we're gonna do parents until so
this is going to find all the elements
between two so starting at the Li
element and going to let's do the div
element so let's see what happens there
okay so it started at the Li element it
ended at the div element every element
in between is just this UL element okay
the the children method goes in the
opposite direction so instead of the
parents until I'm gonna change this to
children and we're not gonna put
anything in the parenthesis here and
let's run that and see what happens
and as you can see this only is going to
traverse a single level down in the Dom
tree so we're just gonna get the span
element if there were multiple Li
elements we would get the children of
each of those elements now I'm going to
change this to span so now we're gonna
get the children of the span elements
and you can see all of these are the
children of the span elements there's a
bunch of 200 s of the span element so
inside the parentheses here we can put
specifically with child we want so I'm
going to put h2 and then run that and
now it's only selecting the child of a
span element that's an h2 element I'm
also going to show you about find so I'm
gonna start this ul and we're gonna find
all children after the UL element that
are specific elements in this case I'm
going to do span so we're going to start
the UL on element and then we're going
to find all children that are span
elements all the way down so let's run
that so we found this span and this pin
and if you want to find all children not
just the span elements you can put in
asterisk here so it starts at the UL
element then it finds all children that
are any type of element and make some
chocolate okay now we're going to talk
about siblings
I was telling you earlier that all these
ones in the middle are siblings of each
other I'm gonna put h2 here and I'm
going to use the method siblings nothing
will be in the parentheses this time and
we get all the siblings of the h2
element not the h2 element but all the
siblings are now chocolate and you may
want to just get specific siblings so
I'm gonna put P for the paragraph tag
now we're just getting the siblings of
an h2 element that are paragraphs
I'm gonna delete this here we're gonna
keep selecting the h2 element but now
I'm gonna show you the next method so
the next just get the next sibling so we
were started on the h2 element and the
next sibling is the h3 element then
there's also next all so we started the
h2 element and then we get all the rest
of the elements afterwards that are
siblings and then we have next unkilled
this time I'm gonna start the span
element and if I go back into the HTML
you'll see that this first span element
has the class child so I'm gonna do span
dot child to select just this span
element just the child span element and
not the parents band element and we're
using the next until method next until
h3 so we start at this this man here and
we select all the elements between the
span and age 3 which is just h2 if we
put a paragraph tag in here then we'll
also select the h3 afterwards so I
showed you next next all and next until
the same things work with preb prep all
and prep until that just gets the
previous element or all the previous
elements or a previous until an element
so I'll just give you one example of
that just the probe if we run that we
start the span and the previous element
is the paragraph again you can also do
breadth all Previn till ok those are all
the main methods for traversing the Dom
parent and child elements took the
description for a list of all the the
methods we went through thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good